pour ton mariage avant de tourner la
page et de quitter la famille soit
fidèle à ton amour tu sais que je t'aime
alors n'avait pas trop de peine
je suis ta petite fille pour toujours
que la vie passe bien vite ne pleure pas
je te revois petit c'est un avec toi que
j'ai ouvert mon coeur à tous les secrets
du bonheur quand on partait tous les
deux main dans la main comme on était
heureux sir ce sera tous les enfants
semblent un beau matin il ya dix ans
quand tu as écrit cette chanson tu
pensais qu'un jour on a chanté ensemble
l olympia franchement non mais par
contre je sais pas si tu te rappelles
j'ai une bonne mémoire quand j'ai écrit
la chanson pour il a dit que c'est une
chanteuse israélienne rappelle blonde
qui passait à l'olympia avec moi et toi
tu avais drôlement aimé la chanson
métier était aussi un peu jalouse
rapport était toute petite était jalouse
alors je t'ai dit écoute ne t'inquiète
pas quand tu seras grande et petite
marie raon la chantera ensemble et c'est
toi qui me l'a rappelé la veille du
mariage et on a chanté à l'occasion du
mariage mais jamais j'aurais cru qu'on
allait le faire à l'olympia et tout ça
c'était pas du tout et les guider moi
j'ai par contre j'ai un petit reproche à
le faire pourquoi ta mis si longtemps
pour me dire que tu voulais être
chanteuse koxie pas parce que j'avais
août
voilà je vous ai faites les vivre et
pourtant tu sais bien que tu aurais
jamais refusé bah oui mais c'était pas
le moment aux us et puis voilà quoi
j'avais très envie de chanter une
chanson avec toi depuis très longtemps
il fallait trouver le moment juste c'est
à dire que comme on dit en anglais ce de
reitmans soit oui dis moi chérie et cet
album que tu prépares il en est où
pour l'instant il n'en est qu'au stade
de maquette quoi je travaille pour
l'instant il n'a parlé de l'album c'est
comme ça mais ce temps je travaille j'ai
beaucoup de travail
l'accord de courant est ce que c'est en
effet voir pendant mon adolescence fait
mandat chez maman chérie qu'est ce que
tu me la fais voir mais enfin pas
méchamment mais et c'est maman ben tu
m'as les études tu me les a complètement
raté
je sais bien que moi je suis un ancien
instituteur je voulais que tu réussisses
dans dans les études j'ai peut-être que
mon mec quand même pas passer ton bac
d'accord mais ça suffit pas tu sayabec
ça suffit pas mais malgré ça je dois
dire que je n'ai jamais faire de
différence entre toi et ton frère et
avec corinne aussi que comme ta soeur tu
le sais bien mais je voulais pas et
finalement malgré tout ce que tu m'en a
fait voir
j'ai un faible pour toi j'ai pas peur de
dire publiquement le pire couvre que je
t'ai fait c'était quoi le pire truc
c'est que tu es organiser une surboum en
cachette de moi alors là je me suis
imaginé tout tout tout le macho que je
suis alors là que tu vas savoir ce que
ça à défiler dans ma tête d'ailleurs tu
te rappelles s'est donné une bonne année
c'était un peu le boxon dominer quoi y
avait beaucoup de monde au wat et
comment tu as dis là le bois savoir
qu'est-ce qui t'énerve plus en moi
de temps en temps tu es un peu
capricieuse et ça ça me plaît pas voilà
c'est allez me dire que c'était ce que
je comprends pas la plaisanterie ah ben
c'est vrai aussi que c'est un cas pas
comme ça le truc est bon alors plus
quittées mer bleue plus en moi ce qui
m'énerve le plus sans toi c'est tu te
trouves un peu lunatique parfois c'est
qu'il faut presque prendre rendez vous
pour parler parfois annonce à la tiédeur
j'accepte pas là où c'est là où
j'accepte c'est quand tu dis que je suis
lunatique mais parfois ça rend ça me
rend un peu paranoïaque en fait parce
que je crois que le mal qu est-ce qui
ont des gros mots ma fille tu mêles le
choc je t'aime chérie
quelle question mon enfant monde de
voile à tresques et les femmes et comme
tu as même si belle soit fidèle un
tonneau
ou n'est pas d'inquiétude on ne craint
pas là
ty je viendrai comme d'habitude chaque
jour que le bonheur partagé toute une
vie
qui semble s'éloigner mais aujourd'hui
c'est un grand jour de joie qui nous
fait tous ouvrir les bras
à